bonjour aujourd'hui nous allons jouer un
jeu extrêmement bizarre puisque on va
séduire un [ __ ] de cheval on est sur
my princess avec un accent incroyable on
va s'appeler horse were hors ue voilà
bah non on peut passer trop long et
bavard fait une première vague qui tombe
à l'eau c'est très rapide un centre
hitman 3-0 à s'appeler isabelle hains
bah ouais j'ai pas d'un spi au mon dieu
ça commence qu'est ce qu'on est en train
de faire un ranch plutôt normal dans une
ville plutôt normal
[ __ ] de cheval tu appelles ça quelque
chose de normal j'ai fait tout ce long
voyage jusqu'à ce petit pays pour une
seule chose je me suis barré d'une
grosse compagnie pour construire ma
propre carrière
mais un jour j'ai perdu de vue ce que je
faisais je n'étais pas désintéressé du
travail en lui-même mais je n'avais pas
la chance mais je n'avais pas la chance
de rencontrer les mecs beau j'ai pas de
penser que l'international qu'elle
rencontre avec ça fait marrer [ __ ] je
me donnais tellement dans mon travail
que ma seule interaction avec les hommes
s'étaient au bureau un bureau plein de
salary man d'âge moyen que personne ne
trouverait attractif et la jeune fille
en moi attendent et de l'excitation et
c'est là que j'ai réalisé mon prince
charmant ne se montrera jamais tant que
je serai coincé dans ce bureau dont j'ai
décidé de prendre des vacances dans ce
ranch
pourquoi un rôle je te demande tu es
bien parce que my pants épisode 1 le
premier galop et je n'ai jamais vu avant
a tort ils ont dessiné une meuf could
animé et après ils sont lâchés sur les
dessins pourri quoi c'était trop
demander de faire que des persos could
ali mais est-ce que ce ranch à des
chevaux bien sûr on entraîne les chevaux
à la course eu ses skis à l'ebbo grèce
qui viennent des beaux gosses on a des
jockeys ah ok mais on dirait pas contre
un se trouve ici tu es ici pour voir des
chevaux huawei hockey en injuste laval
regarder de plus près sa même chemin
nous c'est un chemin normal à il est
juste là
[Musique]
c'est un jeu japonais un sujet si
j'avais au dieu il est tellement sexy
cool fonctionnalité n'est ce pas son nom
et yuma mais il a une tête d'ubs a une
bonne tête du mal madame ne me dites pas
que tu vois un homme à la place du
cheval
et ben si et les hyper sexy laisse moi
deviner tué de l'âne et du cheval
oui c'est ça gênerait que certaines
filles étrange né l'année du cheval voit
parfois les chevaux comme des hommes
très sexy les gens avec cette habilité
sont vraiment très spécial c'est quoi
tout ce qui se passe casse toi avec ta
tête du main sur un vieux coup de cheval
but aïe parle j'étais jamais vu avant
huit hommes puissent y fait le beau
gosse quoi qu'est ce qui t'amène ici je
cherche juste des mecs sexy
[ __ ] labeouf alors aux chaleurs total
c'est un chat un vrai chat rooms
j'aurais jamais dû dire ça oui en
passant t'es quoi exactement ce juste un
cheval de course parfaitement normal il
n'ya rien normal avec toi je suis si
étrange que ça mais je te déteste pas
pour autant il veut plus chauds comme
abba avec sa puce ou [ __ ] de coups de
cheval l'a1 est ce que ce mec même bien
un
est-ce que ce mec même bien non je peux
pas penser à ça c'est un cheval un
[ __ ] de cheval il est ni du verbe et
ni à ses briques les chevaux font c'est
sam ici pourquoi tu ne donnes pas un peu
de nourriture attentes autant ils n'ont
pas de faire acheter de la monnaie du
jeu pour acheter des packs d'eau [ __ ]
de cheval là ah non mais tu rappes
habiller un ouais les carottes juste là
de nuisance au hockey [ __ ] mexès est
dérangeant tamagoshi tape sur la carte
pour nourrir yuma bien sûr et fait
attention huppert l'énergie si tu le
nourris trop hockey et n'oubliez pas de
lui parler en cliquant sur le bouton
aléas du stoa a donc là je les nourris
énergique 30% savait donner l'énergie
way and en islam et mellifères de
l'énergie c'est ça et britz équivalent
d'un bébé
enfin c'est mon côté remis de ce jeu je
veux voir la fois joueur le bisounours à
cambrai il enchaîne la bouffe attend
surtout l'énergie
il arrive plus à s'arrêter ouais mais là
il a plus d'énergie pour gerard ils sont
coupés et pensons coup épandu atteint
faut que je parle qu'est ce que tu
penses des carottes
adacore sa part aux qcm aubry elle on a
bon goût j'aime bien leur couleur orange
ou je ne les aime pas elles sont un
délicieux goût mais qu à l'embrasement
et la geek à 60 d'énergie s'abattant
avant la prochaine fois tu peux lui
parler 29 minutes
non mais non je veux lui parler
maintenant
je alors c'est bon est ce que tu aimes
les ranchs je dis oui la réponse a comme
d'ailleurs motivé dans son sens non je
vais la jouer en mode mystérieux pas
vraiment t'as pas besoin de revenir si
t'aime pas attends attends je lui parle
forgé par est ce que tu aimes les ranchs
ouais carrément ils sont cools n'est ce
pas tu as de bon goût excellent est bien
connu pour son énergie +30 [ __ ] je
suis bien allez je vais arriver aux
coups bas il a plus d'énergie mais il
nous manque tellement rien vas-y je m'en
fous je fais 3 0 ces bons seront ils en
gagnent un peu alors tu m'aimes tombe on
est devenu plus fort il a clairement
beaucoup mangé aujourd'hui il mange
comme un cheval probablement parce que
c'est un cheval
mais ce sera le dernier repas de la
pauvre bête attend quoi son propriétaire
vient de le quitter tu vois ah merde
aussi terrible pauvre petite chose je me
sens désolé pour lui maintenant si
seulement quelqu'un pouvait s'occuper de
lui à la laci seulement tu tues tu sais
quoi à buck tude q2 à il m'a marché
dessus tu deviens fabrication
[Musique]
aïe
1 qu'est ce qu'il se passe est ce que
c'est ce truc qu'on voit dans les films
veux tu devenir mon propriétaire oh ok
cool j'ai hâte de travailler avec toi
mon proprio oui premièrement petit
baisser ce sabot et te calmer un peu
attends je suis sa propriétaire
maintenant est ce une menace
il ya une période de réflexion n'est ce
pas mais je peux sentir mon coeur
s'emballe et est ce que ça pourrait être
[Musique]
la grosse [ __ ]
olalala voilà c'est la fin de l'épisode
1 c'était génial quelle deuxième épisode
isabelle a repris ses esprits et est
revenu à la ferme pour dire qu'elle l'a
quitté mais non mais tu peux pas les
citons l'homme de ta vie mais elle n'a
pas réussi à trouver le moment au regard
dans ce visage si beau et donc qu on m'a
demandé à isabelle de commencer à
l'entraîner mais isabelle est sous le
choc dans le prochain épisode la
formation sur un tapis roulant
une fille amoureuse cheval au visage
d'homme et voilà le rideau ce faire vous
voulez vous écrire une review baal et
halo 6 5 sur 5
mais clairement la définition de la
qualité mieux que la ps4 trop et gratuit
voilà c'est cadeau c'est pour vous et je
ne sais pas c'est une taxe de plus et
qui n'hésitait pas à aller mais bah
écoute et j'espère que si un jour je
trouverais mon prince charmant
au corps du cheval avec un très très
gros pénis et ben voila quand le japon
frappe qu'est ce que ça donne de la
qualité mon gars est à tu veux la note
4,9 aux gars ont pas sur un boss et
gratuite est chargée de tous
tous ont fait monter en off la croate de
france on se marie tooth avec un [ __ ]
de cheval au visage d'animer à l'heure
ce n'est rien a dream sorti bien tour du
monde
[Musique]